I know we have to deal with this
immediately because yeah yeah yeah you
cannot I've never I've never seen anyone
walk in with a gift that large well I've
never seen a talk show on after December
1st without a single Christmas
decoration holiday decoration whatever
you want to say in sight well we're a
little behind
we haven't you're very about December
1st hit if you watch football they all
have the Happy Holidays logos going on
right now
you have nothing Starbucks you know
Starbucks has the holiday cups already
so yes where's yours no you seem
borderline angry about I have really
embraced the holiday spirit this year
and I'm bringing joy to you oh nice so
much for our pledge to remain neutral in
the war on Christmas yeah exactly those
days oh my god that thing is beautiful
Wow isn't this pretty
this is like something my mother would
have made but she didn't this is a you
have a hook this is so handy oh yeah we
had a hook just in case this ever
happens yeah oh god he's lopsided this
is there that's your first Christmas
decoration
[Music]
get too close to the face of the L yeah
who what the hell no that was horrifying
he doesn't look good in close-up no but
really close on the elf may I stroke it
that L was waiting good I cannot take
responsibility for that creepy little
elf you and I share some elves we both
working with Warner Brothers lot that's
right are elves that we share helped put
this together and I probably wouldn't
have picked that elf but you know what
I'm not gonna look this gift horse in
the mouth no you know what you did a
nice thing you came there and you've
made our sets the beginning of cheer
yeah I think cheer begins now keep going
okay you know I want to talk to you and
I've noticed it also in our audience
tonight people have signs for you they
they do yes they do people are excited
people are excited
[Music]
it's very nice table but your fans go to
great lengths to show they can have
something isn't that nice it's it's
really sweet is really endearing that
you know whether it be through notes or
through what sometimes they send gifts I
did get and I brought this out too
I had it placed earlier I got recently
this gift this is a little this is a lot
less creepy than the elf you can get
close there I I've heard these are
called ami ami this is all crochet then
amazing it's a shell this crocheted
Sheldon yeah and it's the sweetest thing
it's this woman named Jackie and she
lives in Canada I think and I don't know
I think it's the cutest thing in the
world
yeah it's beautiful yeah I think in fact
I would I would buy a matrix but you
know what I mean I'd love it if it is
there any chance that could replace the
oh that's not a bad idea
Jim you have made I'm not gonna sleep at
night knowing a choice I hope Jackie's
okay with this I don't know what her
religious feelings are towards the
holiday season but they're sort of now
oh I don't want to hurt him you're there
are there okay there we go
[Applause]
get in there the alphas creepily made it
much worse
I don't know whether to apologize to
Jacky or if she's enjoying this I please
know there was no ami harmed in the
making of this wreath we are going to
take a commercial we're going to consult
lawyers and get this all taken